do you want to learn aws but not too
sure where to start do you want to build
your technical skills and land a job in
the cloud industry getting an aws
certification is one of the best things
you can do to start your cloud learning
journey and if you clicked on this video
you're probably either already studying
for an aws notification or thinking of
studying for one first of all let me
just say getting an abs certification
isn't something you can do overnight it
takes a lot of time and effort
especially if you're quite new to the
tech industry if you've watched my
previous videos you might have seen that
i actually failed my aws syslop's
associate exam twice before passing on
the third attempt and so in this video
i'm going to be sharing with you my
personal experience of studying for 80
certifications and provide a
step-by-step roadmap you can use
starting as a complete beginner
alright so may of 2020 around two and a
half years ago i joined aws as an intern
in a non-technical team at the time i
barely knew what cloud computing was but
after speaking with a few solutions
architects at aws i thought to myself
wow the role was actually pretty cool
and you know what that's what i want to
be after graduating university but the
problem was i needed to improve my
technical skills and that's where my
cloud computing journey actually started
so in august of 2020 three months into
my internship i began preparing for the
aws cloud practitioner exam it took me
around three weeks and at the end of
august i was able to pass with an exam
score of 854 getting the aws cloud
practitioner certification really helps
increase my understanding of cloud
computing and this is a certification i
recommend every beginner start with if
you're someone preparing for this
certification i recommend checking out
this video i made on how i was able to
pass the exam in three weeks okay so
after obtaining my cloud practitioner
assert i wanted to dive deeper and keep
exploring aws services this is because
the cloud practitioner exam only taught
me what individual adb services could be
used for for example i learned that
amazon ec2 provides scalable compute
capacity in the cloud but i wanted to
understand how multiple aws services
could be used together to help companies
meet their business and technical goals
long story short i ended up getting the
solutions arctic associate so september
2020 the developer associates at
november 2020 the sysops december 2020
and finally the solutions arctic
professional cert december 2021 this
journey honestly wasn't an easy one at
the start i felt very lost and had all
sorts of questions you know what are the
best resources to use what order should
i do the certifications and how long
does it actually take to complete each
certification this is why in this video
i want to share with you a step-by-step
roadmap outlining the exact resources i
used the recommended time frame for each
certification and my advice to you after
spending hours and hours studying for
aws certifications quick pause if you've
been studying for adb certifications but
find it hard to concentrate you may want
to invest in a pair of noise cancelling
earbuds soundcore by inco has recently
released their new space series and have
kindly sent over the space a40 noise
cancelling earbuds for me to try out
i've been using these earbuds for a few
weeks now and it's been amazing for
helping me stay focused while doing my
work these earbuds reduce noise by up to
98 and have a 50 hour playback time
which means i only need to charge it
every couple of days i also just love
how comfortable they are they fit nicely
and have a lightweight design one super
cool feature they have is adaptive noise
cancelling which automatically
identifies noise around me and selects a
suitable level of noise cancelling so
whether i'm on a plane or just in my
room i'll be able to enjoy high quality
audio if you're interested in checking
out these earbuds i have a link to them
in the video description below thank you
again soundcloud for sending over these
earbuds now let's get back to the video
okay first of all i just want to say
that there's no one correct path when it
comes to getting aws certifications on
the screen you can see here all the
certifications aws has available there
are many routes and pathways to getting
aws certified but here is my personal
recommendation so starting off as a
beginner with no aws experience i
recommend first watching a bunch of
videos to get a basic understanding of
what is the cloud why should you learn
it what are the benefits of cloud for
companies this will help you become more
excited about your cloud learning
journey and as a result increase your
motivation next you can start preparing
for your first aws certification some
people recommend going straight for the
solutions arctic associate cert but if
you're a beginner you'll find the cloud
practitioner certification a lot easier
i found that doing this foundational
certification helps me gain more
confidence and made me feel more ready
to tackle additional certifications
after getting the cloud practitioners
cert you can aim for an associate level
set here you can see the estimated
amount of time to prepare for them the
order of setting these associate exams
don't matter too much but people usually
do the solutions arctic associate one
first followed by developer associate
and then sysops because sysops is
usually the hardest for most people
these associate exams have a lot of
overlap so once you complete one of them
you might find that it's easier for you
to study for the other ones professional
level certs are next on the roadmap and
these ones are a lot more challenging
and have more specific questions i
didn't put an estimated study time
because it really depends on how much
hands-on experience you already have
with aws either through projects or
real-world experience these
certifications are much harder so i
would recommend completing all the
associate exams first before tackling
the professional ones specialty
certifications come next and these
certifications require you to have aws
cloud knowledge in a specialized domain
so even though you can probably sit
these exams before the professional ones
specialty exams need you to have more
specific knowledge that builds on deeper
aws concepts so my suggestion would be
to focus on associate and professional
level certs before tackling the
specialty ones and of course there are
many other routes to getting edibles
certifications for example if you have a
passion for machine learning you might
choose to start with the solutions
arctic
it and then go straight to the machine
learning specialty center there really
is no right or wrong path depending on
your personal and career goals you might
choose to do three certifications five
certifications or maybe even all 12
certifications but make sure you don't
spend too much time trying to figure out
which certifications to study for this
will lead to something called analysis
paralysis which means you'll end up
overthinking and not taking any action
at all my biggest piece of advice to you
all is to make sure you focus on
building skills and not just collecting
certs at the end of the day it's the
skills and the knowledge that you gain
from the certifications that you can
bring onto your technical interviews for
the solutions arctic role the cloud
engineer role or any other role you
might be interested in alright if you've
watched up until this point of the video
i really appreciate you sticking around
please comment below with the phrase
let's get certified just so i know who
watched this video all the way through
and if you have watched until the end
you'll probably enjoy this video i made
where i walk through step by step how i
study for adidas certifications